welcome back everyone to streaming the
galaxy my name is rocket riley and today
we're going to be going over a quick
recap of everything that happened in the
first two seasons of netflix's original
series you
but before we get started if you're new
to the channel please hit the subscribe
button and click the bell icon to be
notified when we upload a new video also
spoil a warning for all the events that
happen in the first two seasons of you
the first season starts us off with joe
goldberg the manager of a new york
vintage bookstore
nice good looking and charming he seems
like the perfect guy the only problem
he's a sociopathic murderer with a
loving hero complex
joe meets and falls in love with
gwynevere beck an mfa student hoping to
become an award-winning writer
joe's inner dialogue throughout the
season is directed towards beck and he
begins stalking her on social media and
following her physically
he even goes so far as to sneak into her
apartment while she's gone
when a drunken beck falls onto the
subway tracks he saves her but he steals
her phone in the process joe then lures
beck's spoiled boyfriend benji into the
basement of the bookstore where he hits
him in the head with a mallet and locks
him in a glass cage
we're then introduced to beck's
enormously rich friend peach who is
suspicious of joe
in the meantime joe decides to kill
benji in the cage as he believes he's
protecting beck by doing so
joe and beck begin dating and peach's
suspicion of joe continues to grow
after peach's failed suicide attempt in
order to regain beck's affections joe
realizes that peach is actually in love
with beck and he decides to get rid of
her
he attacks her while on her own in
central park but she recovers
during her recovery joe follows peach
and beck to peach's family mansion in
greenwich after beck leaves peach
discovers joe and points a gun at him
they wrestle for a moment and peach is
shot
joe writes a fake suicide note for her
and he leaves the scene
joe starts seeing beck's therapist dr
nikki but going by the name of paul
after joe accuses beck of cheating on
him with dr nikki beck breaks up with
joe joe then begins happily dating a
woman named karen minty and beck gets a
book deal after writing about peach's
death
joe and beck begins seeing each other
again in secret after a few months and
joe then breaks up with karen who warns
beck about joe's suspicious past
later joe recalls his ex-girlfriend
candace cheating on him and then joe
killing the man who she cheated on him
with
he also recalls their final fight
leading to him taking her out to the
woods and smacking her head on a piece
of wood after she tried to escape
leaving her for dead
beck looks into their relationship as
her suspicions grow and it's revealed
that beck actually was cheating on joe
with dr nikki
after fighting they make up but beck
then discovers a box with her old phone
benjies and peaches phones and other
gross mementos joe then locks her in the
glass cage for protection
while in the cage beck tries to fake
understanding of joe's actions writing a
story which blames dr nikki for
everything joe had done
after stabbing joe in the cage with a
typewriter piece and trying to escape
joe kills beck off-screen
several months later we learned that joe
used beck's writing to frame dr nikki
who went to prison putting joe in the
clear
the season ends with candace who is
presumed to be dead at this point
entering the bookstore and telling joe
that they have some unfinished business
season two begins with joe recalling the
conversation with candace who threatened
to make him suffer after what he did to
her joe then flees to los angeles where
he takes the fake name of will
bettelheim and gets a job at a book cafe
called an avrin there he meets love
quinn daughter of the owners of an avern
and twin sister to forty quinn the
store's eccentric manager
love who joe directs his inner dialogue
toward this season takes joe out for the
evening and you can see her start to
fall for him
it's then revealed that joe was stalking
love before getting his apartment and
before applying for work at an average
it's also revealed that joe stole the
name will bettleheim from a man who he
has locked in the glass cage this time
in a storage unit
joe finds out that the real will
bettleheim owes 50 000 to a man named
jasper who cuts off joe's finger because
he thought that joe was will
after a final confrontation in the
storage unit joe kills jasper and gets
his finger reattached
joe continues stalking love and we meet
joe's neighbors ellie a 15 year old
aspiring filmmaker and delilah a
reporter who tells joe that she thinks
she was raped by a popular comedian
named henderson
joba friends loves twin 40 an aspiring
film writer producer and director
joe finds out that ellie is spending
time with henderson so he sneaks his way
into a party at henderson's house and 40
joins
at the party 40 has a drug field
breakdown which is caught on camera joe
takes 40 home where love takes care of
him and joe and love get together and
start dating
joe learns about a secret room in
henderson's house so he breaks in and
discovers pictures of underage girls and
leader knox henderson who was attempting
to drug ellie at the time down a flight
of stairs killing him
while out of town 40 meets a woman going
by the name of amy who is actually
candace following joe after seeing the
video of 40 at henderson's party
falling in love with love joe joins her
at a wellness retreat for her parents
anniversary fordy and candice still
using the name of amy come to the
retreat as well
and candace convinces forty to adapt
beck's book into a screenplay
love suspicious of candace hires a
private investigator to follow her
candice breaks into joe's apartment but
love is waiting for her love learned
candace's identity and she confronts joe
who convinces her that he fled new york
to get away from the obsessive candice
and that her darker accusations are
simply lies
love breaks up with joe anyway and he
tries to find a way to win her back
delilah the apartment manager and joe's
neighbor looks in joe's apartment for
more information on henderson and she
finds the keys to his storage unit
joe finds her there and locks her in the
cage
after 40 drugs joe during their final
hours and rewriting his screenplay joe
reconciles with love but loses some time
forty finally finishes the script
correctly deducing that beck's
ex-boyfriend killed her instead of dr
nikki because he believes that he did
the same to their family's au pair after
an abusive relationship
after waking up the next morning joe
races to the storage unit and finds
delilah dead in the cage
candace finds jo in the cage and locks
him inside she calls love telling her to
come to the storage unit to prove that
joe is dangerous but love kills candace
and professes her love for joe
she admits to killing forty's au pair
and delilah both to protect the ones
that she cares about
she also tells joe that she is pregnant
with his child who she believes to be a
girl
joe decides to stay with love and start
a family together but forty learns joe's
true pass from dr nikki who's in prison
and tries to keep joe away from love 40
points a gun at joe but joe is saved by
officer fincher a police detective who
had a relationship with delilah who
shoots and kills 40.
40 is blamed for henderson and candace's
deaths but the quinn family sweeps it
under the rug with lawyers and money
joe then starts to give money to ellie
who moves east to avoid child protective
services and joe and love move into a
new house the season ends with joe
returning to his obsessive behavior
turning his inner dialogue toward their
new female neighbor
so far joe and love have killed a total
of 10 people as well as indirectly
causing the death of forty quinn the
third season of you comes out on october
15th so it'll be interesting to see if
this number continues to grow
and there's your full recap of
everything you need to know before
watching season 3 of you if you enjoyed
today's video please hit the like button
and if you have ideas that you'd like to
share for future videos please drop them
in the comments section below also don't
forget to subscribe for more great
content
from everyone here at stream in the
galaxy we hope you have a great day and
thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you